mon
depuis quelques années il la variété de
produits au comptoir délai est
grandissante
on parle de segmentation et d'une
fragmentation de l'offre est je pense
que l'idée c'est vraiment de répondre
aux besoins des consommateurs
je pense qu'il faut redorer l'image
délais en termes de valeur ajoutée de
bénéfices santé
pour ce faire l'industrie identifie les
tendances qui motive les choix des
consommateurs
l'acte en ce qui fait un lait et avoine
donc un mix de loi son d'avoine avec le
lait on a des des produits qui vise
justement de la conservation sur 70
jours bien entendu on ne le bio le lait
se présente sous un nouveau jour pour
répondre aux préoccupations
environnementales de santé et le désir
du consommateur d'acheter des produits
locaux
c'est beaucoup le transformateur qui
vont tester des produits ou vous
regardait les houmas concurrence mais la
compétition s'élargit évidemment avec
les nouvelles tendances on a évidemment
les autres joueurs un à ses nationaux
internationaux comme nous il ya eu
également l'émergence de paye de petits
joueurs et niches qui répondent à un
besoin aussi capable de développer très
rapidement dans deux trois mois on est
capable de sortir une nouvelle saveur
produit une égale fond tandis qu'en
général c'est des choses qui peuvent
prendre 18 mois 24 mois même trois
certaines situations
l'objectif des transformateurs comme des
bannières c'est d'offrir un produit qui
se démarque idéalement qui n'existe pas
encore je vous demande des consommateurs
d'avoir de la variété c'est plus juste
avoir du lait normal ils veulent
vraiment une variété
à la laiterie chagnon de waterloo le
dernier-né il est commercialisé sous le
nom de l'est à 2
[Musique]
le lait à 2 et les plus gras avec 5 % de
matière grasse
il est produit par un troupeau de vaches
brunes ise et contient de la protéine
bêta cazine à deux c'est devenu vraiment
de tendance envoyer des produits
apparaître ici et là et c'est de là
qu'on a fait nos recherches et qu'on a
vu que vraiment une demande pour sa
d'avoir des leds plus du digérable plus
facile à gérer
quand on regarde toutes les études
cliniques effectués au cours des
dernières années on se rend compte que
les effets bénéfiques tullet à deux sont
davantage associés au niveau gastro
intestinal
le chercheur car julien s'est intéressée
aux effets du génotype à deux
présidentielles
les gens qui est en avoir jeûné tablant
sur la touche lorsque cette personne
consomme d'une heure due aux pratiquants
ou les heureux ont moins de problèmes
gastro intestinaux
pour moi c'est pas encore une certitude
parce que ce n'est pas suffisamment
d'études ont été réalisées
certains chercheurs croient que le lait
à 2 aurait des effets bénéfiques sont
les maladies cardiovasculaires le
diabète ou même la santé du cerveau tout
ce sont des hypothèses qui reste à
vérifier donc le pas suffisamment de
travaux de recherche et veulent des
bourses et pour ces sujets nous et on
voit quand même de plusieurs producteurs
qui ont commencé à converser l'entrepôt
donc il y en intérêts en effet pour le
neo 2 chez des producteurs
la marque natrel d'agropur est
particulièrement réputée pour ses
produits finement filtré sans lactose ou
biologiques leur plus récent les à
valeur ajoutée et mise en marché et le
nétrel plus qui contient deux fois plus
de protéines que le lait ordinaire
bien évidemment la notion de protéines
et en ressentez à 1 ora de satisfaction
en termes de satiété
c'était des éléments clés consommateurs
nous le demandait faire face tout scellé
à valeur ajoutée ne sont pas soumis à la
réglementation qui dit que le prix du
lait norme est évidemment un la valeur
ajoutée
va être va être distribué 1 va être
vendu à un prix plus élevé évidemment
c'est normal parce qu'on voit une valeur
ajoutée aussi donc ça coûte plus cher
aux transformateurs de produits et oui
le consommateur est prêt à payer ça pour
avoir des produits locaux il faut
s'attendre à débourser environ 40 % de
plus pour un lait biologique 60% pour 1
laissant la dose est un peu plus du
double pour les à deux et ça ne tient
pas compte des différences de prix entre
marchands
quand je regarde le pur filtre d'accord
le judas à sherbrooke miles entre les
différents marchands j'ai un écart de 6
% quand même depuis
et puis quand je regarde le lait bio
j'ai un accord de 8 pouces à certaines
laiteries régionales comme la laiterie
des trois vallées la ferme lampron ou la
laiterie nutrinor offre des produits du
terroir délais avec une saveur locale
vaches au pâturage va chier au foin sec
ça peut altérer le goût du lait on voit
le nutrinor qui a sont les nordiques
donc toute différenciation pour ce
relais d'une terre munich doit avoir un
goût différent que si tu prends le lait
de 30,41 mélanger ensemble
souvent c'est pas le même goût nous
c'est vraiment ça va suivre les saisons
le goût va changer un peu et c'est un
coût qui est plus à l'ancienne avec 5%
de grenade 6 plus petit joueur exerce
une certaine pression sur les plus
grands et chacun tient à conserver son
espace sur les présentoirs d'épicerie
sac irrite davantage de compétition pour
les sports stable puisque les cheveux
que mon produit soit visible et
certainement al'avantage de détaillants
je vous dirais parce que le la valeur
d'un espace tablette augmente donc c'est
clair qu'ils monnayent le sport style
est puis veulent ils veulent occuper
on est en augmentation constante sur ses
produits sur tout ce qui est à dieu il
ya une demande pour ça alors c'est nous
on est heureux mais c'est sûr que si le
produit était mais les volumes
augmentent quelqu'un va nous copier 6
pour un marché qui perdait des plumes il
n'y a pas si longtemps il semble que
l'innovation au comptoir délai n'a pas
fini de nous surprendre
il ya dix ans on avait dit des boissons
de soya
c'était quand même assez marginal l'on
voit que ça prend beaucoup d'importance
sandy quand même long sur le où le
marché se dirige je vois tout le moyen
du segment du marché
j'ai l'impression qu'on va connaître
beaucoup de mouvements dans les secteurs
et les ti notamment pour aller répondre
aux nouvelles tendances consommateurs
post pandémie et je pense que inde est
un des éléments qui est là pour rester
c'est le souci de la santé du bien-être
consommateurs